now so far on the program we've heard
quite a lot from people with suggestions
some more critical than others for the
government so now it's time to talk to
the man who's been leading the response
while the Prime Minister recovers from
coronavirus the Foreign Secretary and
the first secretary of state Dominic Rob
thank you for being with us today now
thanks Sophie more than 20,000 people
have now died in hospital after testing
positive for coded 19 20,000 I mean now
last month the chief scientific adviser
said keeping the number below 20,000
would be good outcome for the UK this is
clearly a bad one worse than we were
hoping for
foreign secretary are you worried
okay this has been incredibly worrying
time and the fact that we've passed that
grim milestone of 20,000 of course is
heartbreaking for every one of those
who've lost loved ones we know though
that this has been an unprecedented
crisis I don't think you can blame the
chief medical officers who were pressed
repeatedly to try and put an estimate on
how long it would take how many people
would pass away what we do know is as we
go through the peak of this crisis two
critical things have happened which were
part of our plan the first one is as we
go through we've flattened the peak
because the public have followed the
social distancing guidelines very
carefully that has been successful and
and I'm afraid it's sir allottee that
the death toll would have been even
higher we hadn't have introduced those
measures at the right time and frankly
if the public hadn't have been
overwhelmingly supportive of those
measures the second critical thing is
that we've made sure we've got the
critical care capacity in the NHS the
ventilators the the the ICU capacity to
deal with this crisis at its peak and
that means that the NHS hasn't been
overwhelmed and has been able to cope
not just with coronavirus but also the
other critical care needs that people
have but as we come through this crisis
we're at a delicate and dangerous stage
and we need to make sure the next steps
are sure-footed which is why we're
proceeding very cautiously and we're
sticking to the medical advice the
scientific advice with the social
distancing measures at this time whilst
doing all of the homework if you like to
make sure that we're prepared in due
course for the next phase we're talking
about the next steps there you're
talking about the next phase and Nicola
Sturgeon has had what she calls a
grown-up conversation about how that
might look in Scotland when some of the
lockdown measures do end up changing and
just heard Andy Burnham do the same why
don't you trust people enough to tell
them what it is that you're considering
we do we set out five tests I set them
out about ten days ago which said we're
coming through the peak of this crisis
but until we've got frankly the the
death rate down until we've got the
infection rate down until we can be
confident that we don't end up
patatas second peak than the virus which
would cause more deaths which would
damage the economy which result in a
second lockdown and as Andrew Bailey the
governor of the Bank of England said
this week would actually result in a big
blow not just to the economy but to
public confidence until we can be
confident based on the scientific advice
that will make sure footage steps going
forward which protect life but also
preserve our way of life frankly it's
not responsible to start speculating
about the individual measures and I read
to Nicolas sturgeons the Scottish
government report on this and it's 25
pages long and it sticks very carefully
and consistently to the five test that
we've set out and so we'll be guided by
the scientific advice and we want to
make sure that as we approach the point
at which we can make changes we're
guided by the science and as I said
overwhelmingly taking care of the health
of the public but also making sure we
take shore footed steps
I think anything else is irresponsible
frankly for all the other people that's
saying that we should be setting out
proposals in detail I haven't actually
seen any of those particular people
suggesting specific things and I think
they're right not to at this stage
because until we've got the evidence
from the scientists and the scientific
groups and also until we've tested what
what those proposals would the impact
they would have I don't think it would
be a responsible thing to do it would
only create more uncertainty in the
public's mind when actually they need
the reassurance that we're taking the
right measures as I said based on the
evidence at the right time it's not
amazing they're saying that it will just
create more uncertainty for the public I
mean the public have really followed the
guidance surely they are intelligent
enough to work out that what you're
laying out isn't things that they can
expect to do right now well actually if
you look at the public mood it's
overwhelmingly they're concerned that we
might ease up too soon but let me just
give you an illustration if we started
proposing one or other measure that's
subsequently down the track we found out
we couldn't implement I think we'd be
saying that we jump the gun you'd be
criticizing us for that and I think the
public would be getting mixed messaging
so what we've said very clearly is we
set out the five tests for what the next
transitional phase would look like won't
be just going back it will be a new
normal if you like with social
distancing measures adapted to areas
which are currently closed off and
and we'll make sure we're guided by the
scientific evidence and the scientists
themselves have said when I set out
those five tests ten days ago they said
easing up on any of the measures now
would be dangerous and irresponsible and
they also said that in about three weeks
time from that point so another couple
of weeks they'd have more evidence and
of course the more we get the rate of
deaths down the more we get the rate of
infections down the greater flexibility
we'll have so we'll take the right right
decisions but but I just make this point
the Andrew Bailey governor of the Bank
of England made this point as well if we
take the wrong measures now it's not
just the risk to public health also the
risk to the economy because we'd get a
second spike a second lockdown and that
would be a serious blow to public
confidence so we're going to take the
right decisions at the right moment and
as I said make sure the next step is a
sure-footed one in this crisis
you've been very firm saying that you're
following the scientific advice and
talking about what scientists have been
telling telling you so why wouldn't you
publish that scientific advice and even
just the names of the scientists who are
giving you their bodies well sage do
release and their advice subsequent as
normally about a couple of weeks down
the track so it's properly test and
carefully checked before being put it
out we don't release as a matter of
practice the names of all the members of
Sage because the risk of them being
subject to pressure undue influence
things like that but I don't think it
Sophie realistically you can say there's
been a lack of transparency we've had
the chief scientific adviser so patrick
balance the chief medical officer
professor chris witty along with
politicians like me standing up on a
daily basis answering the questions
setting out their advice and making sure
that we communicate as clearly as
possibly to the public what that advice
is and it's interesting saying that i'm
saying that you're not being transparent
you were saying but earlier that and if
you did one thing then jonas would
criticize you and i level you with you
know the poll out by Sky News last week
showed that people trust politicians
like you a lot more than journalists
like me when it comes to these dealing
with the corona virus epidemic but at
the same time you know my job is to try
and get answers and it does feel like on
some things we're not really sure what
those answers are you know we don't know
what the plan is or what the thinking is
around
the lockdown exit we don't know who's on
the committee of scientists we don't get
that scientific advice until it's
slightly delayed you know you can't
blame us for ants aren't screaming these
questions and it does feel as if there
are some things that you're not telling
us why not I don't blame you so if you
have come on the show because I embrace
that scrutiny I've done the press
conferences because it's critically
important we welcome Parliament getting
back up and running responsibly with the
social distancing and the technology to
do it responsibly we embrace that
scrutiny it's really important I'm just
also explaining to you as along with the
things that we have set out why there
are certain things that if we jump with
a gun they would be irresponsible and
precarious the stage wrap with this
virus and I've talked about the
achievement that we've had with the
public with the NHS and flattening the
curve as we come through the peak
keeping NHS capacity so it isn't
overwhelmed and that's really important
and the the delicate stage wrap is if we
ease up too soon we risk a second spike
but the virus that would create
unnecessary deaths and that would be
deeply responsible and at the same time
it would precipitate probably another
lockdown and as Andrew Bailey the
governor the Bank of England has said
that would not just be damaging for the
economy because it would prolong the
pain but it would be a blow to public
confidence so we do have to take the
right steps at the right time we no one
is clamoring more to get on to the
second phase where we cannot just safely
and responsibly protect people's lives
but preserve our way of life but I'm
also acutely conscious because I'm
talking to Chris witty and Patrick
valance and getting that advice that we
need to make sure footed steps and do
the responsible thing at the right time
and so we're monitoring the evidence
very carefully we're doing all the
homework on all of those areas of what
the second phase would look like and
we'll make sure that we can do so and
announce the detail of it where it's
clear and it's reassuring and it's
articulate in the detail in a way that's
responsible and doesn't actually end up
creating mixed messages and I think
that's the responsible thing that
politicians like me should do now
testing testing is going to be
absolutely critical in the months ahead
the Mel and Sunday report so that
British scientists have developed a new
immunity test to effectively find out
who've had
Rhona virus if you have antibodies to it
apparently ministers have ordered 50
million of them is that true I think
we're certainly looking at that the the
antibody test is important because it
can tell whether you've had the virus
there's also the swab test which says
whether you currently have got the virus
and we're looking at all of these
measures to manage and try and bring an
end to the corona virus there are other
things as well we're looking at the
possibility of a vaccine that's not
likely to come to fruition this year but
it could be very important if we get
multiple waves of corona virus globally
down the track there's also therapeutics
and drugs it's not talked about quite so
much in the media but that's an
important Avenue for us to really
explore and to drive forward because of
course if we could get the death rate
from this virus down and actually for
most people and the overwhelming
majority of people started to resemble
something more like flu would be much
more manageable so whether it's the
tests the therapeutics and the vaccines
we're making sure we're driving forward
as swiftly and as and as carefully as
possible so we're in the best place in
the medium term to be able to manage and
eliminate this crisis for good and in a
sustainable way and in a responsible way
a testing of course whether or not you
have corona virus at that particular
moment will also be very important and
so that people can make sure that they
isolate and Tet trace anyone they come
into contact with now in just four days
time we're supposed to be carrying out a
hundred thousand of those tests every
day the latest figures show just twenty
eight thousand seven hundred tests
carried out in a 24 hour period I mean
I'm reading a petition are you actually
going to meet that
well you're right about that for in
terms of the latest figures for tests
carried out although it's a bit old now
because as we come through the weekend
we've got new data our capacity for
carrying out tests is now at 51,000 per
day so we've passed the halfway line to
our target and there's two things in the
last week that really matter and you
always get the exponential increase in a
project like this in the last week as
the capacity comes on tap so within the
engine making sure well the new data
will come out so the data is always got
a lag to it but on Monday we'll get the
updated data and I think there's two
things which have happened which will
give us confidence that we actually are
on track to meet the target first of all
with the NHS portal we're making sure
that people can access the test either
through home kits through any one of the
31 drive-thru centers and increasingly
with mobile testing labs and the
military are helping disseminate those
spread those across the country the
second thing is we focused initially on
NHS workers then on care workers we've
now broadened it to include all
essential workers and so I think we're
going to see a big surge in the last
week and we're on track to hit that
target testing is really important not
just in the way we've described before
about eliminating the virus for good
sustainably down the track but also as
we consider the second phase it can help
us and give us more room for maneuver in
terms of easing up on the measures
because you can monitor very carefully
who has and who hasn't got the virus so
it's really important now there's been a
lot of criticism of course and
well-documented criticism saying the
government was too slow to get testing
up and running in the previous months
another area where we've been slower
than other countries is quarantine
people who traveled to the United
Kingdom there's reports out today that
in The Sunday Telegraph that that is
going to change at some point so can you
just be clear is the government going to
start limiting and flights coming to the
United Kingdom or quarantine people once
they arrive in the United Kingdom
so first of all I don't accept your
assertion that we've been too slow to
act as I mentioned before we've taken
the right measures at the right time
because we want to capture the peak of
the virus and flatten it and make sure
the NHS is able to cope at the right
moment in time if you go too early with
your measures and I think there'll be
international experience when we're done
with this crisis that will bear this out
if you go too early you end up trying to
come out of it too early and that risks
the second spike in relation to measures
at the border in terms of people coming
into the country the advice so far has
always been made almost no impact on the
spread of the virus because of the
decrease in the number of people
traveling and the fact that the
transmission rate in within the UK is
high but we've continually throughout
tested this with the scientists and with
the chief medical officer to make sure
that as the evidence changes or as we
move to a second place we're able to
take any new measures that that are
necessary so that's something that we
will be looking at and it could include
the testing for people coming in it
could include social distancing measures
and we'll make sure as I said
particularly as we consider any
transition to a second phase that we're
absolutely on top of the scientific
evidence and are taking all the measures
that are necessary to protect people's
health to protect a life but also to
preserve our way of life as we go
forward economically and socially now we
are running out of time but you've been
deputizing for the prime minister while
he recovers how is he he's good he's on
good spirits and he's taken the time and
taken the doctor's advice to to rebuild
his strength he's going to be back at
work full-time properly at the helm on
Monday and as you can imagine with the
prime minister he's raring to go
and I spoke to him I spoken to him every
day this week we've made sure that he's
a rest of everything that's going on and
we had a meeting at Chequers and the
Chancellor joined and various members of
the top team so I think he's right to
have taken the time he did to make sure
he can bounce back but he's looking
forward to getting back at the the reins
on Monday okay and now a you of course
have been deputizing for the prime
minister as I said and
you took over from the Prime Minister
when he was incapacitated it's the kind
of thing that I'm sure that you never
expect you will ever have to do in the
circumstances that you did so I'm
interested to know you know how did you
find out that you were going to be doing
this role who told you and has it been
difficult to balance you know the need
to show leadership at this time of
crisis but also of course not really
wanting to I guess do anything that
Boris Johnson wouldn't do he said look
at unprecedented situation the cabinet
secretary and other officials explained
the situation to me my first instinct
was obviously be worried for the Prime
Minister but I knew he was in great
hands it's in Thomas's but frankly with
the country going through this crisis on
its knees and with the Prime Minister
are stricken with a deadly virus the
only thing I was focused on is stepping
up to the plate and not letting my Prime
Minister down and try not let my country
down and the last two weeks have been a
challenge but we've had a great team
effort in cabinet everyone has been
focused on what they've got to do and I
think that they've performed
exceptionally well it's a team effort
and of course the country I think
there's been a real strong unity of
purpose as we go through the this very
difficult period particularly with a
milestone of 20,000 deaths and so I mean
I can only pay tribute to those in the
frontline and the British public for
following the guidance and stepping up
to the plate but my role is a small part
of that well I think we'd certainly
sharing the tribute today's are on the
front line and just very finely and
there's unconfirmed rumors and reports
that kim jeong-hoon the leader of North
Korea has died now your foreign
secretary so I'm sure that your best
place to you know try and answer this
question if anyone can do you know if
he's dead
no we're reports are unincorporated I've
seen the international media report but
we don't have any verified state to play
on that yet but obviously we're
following it very carefully those
reports